hello and welcome back to another video
today we're going to be talking about
rojin z so spoiler alert an old man
reaches out to someone he wets his bed
and calls out for help he's lying on the
floor in his bed sick pleading to be
looked after it's the early 21st century
and japan like most other countries is
dealing with an aging population as the
population of the elderly grows so does
the demand for care which the younger
generation aren't always ready or able
to meet a team is having a discussion in
a meeting and a man steps in apologizing
for being late the aging population is
the center of the discussion to address
the lack of resources and treat the
number of aiding seniors suffering from
heart diseases and weak digestive
systems the man presenting introduced
everyone with project z
we're back in the old man's house now
who looks extremely sick he's not alone
a nurse is doing his laundry politely
she suggests the old man not to push the
panic button just because he's wet his
bed the button is to be used for a life
or death crisis
suddenly loud bangs are heard and
someone's at the door the nurse rushes
to open the door and a bunch of men in
suits walking uninvited it's the same
men who were discussing the growing
elderly population earlier and it looks
like they're here to take the old man
away to make him the subject of their
experiment upon asking the girl says
that she's a student nurse and takes
care of the ill during her off days as
the men in suits take the old man with
them they ask the nurse to tag along too
the ministry has chosen this man for
conducting an experiment that will
revolutionize the care of the old these
men have permission from his next of kin
the nurse haruko is with her friends in
the college classroom one of her friends
asks her to join the scientists in the
lab where he'll be introducing the
machine design for taking care of the
elderly the demonstration happening in
the physics lab is for the media
journalists and the media have gathered
around in the physics lab waiting to see
the equipment in action
the first ever elderly person to enjoy
its care is takazawa the old bed-ridden
man behold it's the z001 this equipment
is believed to be a breakthrough in the
care of the elderly the cr1 is robotic
hospital bed that's operated by a
computer it can provide entire care for
the patient including dispensing food
and medicine removing waste bathing and
exercising the patient while he or she
is resting within the bed's frame with
just a touch of a button you can program
the machine to perform certain types of
actions depending on the type of care
that the ill patient needs the machine
also has a built-in system to take care
of their mental needs just touch the
button and screens will appear in front
of the patients allowing them to watch
the news and even play games like chess
or balloon bomber last but not least the
z001 can also monitor the patient's
vitals such as blood pressure and heart
rate to ensure they remain healthy if
any of the vitals are unstable the
computer runs a diagnostics test if the
patient's medical history is programmed
into the computer in advance it will
even suggest medication and appropriate
patient care in a situation where the
machine has exhausted its medical skills
it transmits the information to the
patient's loved ones or family doctors
to take the immediate decision
the computer can also detect natural
disasters and provide protection in case
of a burglary it can even build a
fictitious personality to become a
companion for its patient it's a sixth
generation computer and is autonomous
self-aware and capable of learning
adapting and even upgrading itself and
because it's all powered by an on-board
nuclear reactor you'll never have to
worry about power outages the bed with
the patient lying within would become
automatically sealed in concrete should
there be a meltdown
haruko has one question she's concerned
if the machine cares about mr takazawa's
feelings it seems all the man in the
suit care about is liberating society
from the care of the aching bedridden
elderly people sitting in the room are
impressed by the machine already now
it's time for a press conference looks
like mr takazawa isn't happy and haruko
somehow knows it female nurses are
concerned that machines are cold-hearted
while male nurses think it's a great
invention since it will liberate them
from taking care of their elderly
parents while they can take a leap in
their careers a girl walks in and tells
haruko there's something unusual on her
computer all the computers including
hers are stuck on the screen says haruko
the friend suggests taking a print of
the screen to see if there's a pattern
since the name is appearing in a strange
sequence
haruko randomly clicks on the computer
and the message on the screen changes
it's mr takazawa trying to reach out to
haruko it's a cry for help haruko and a
bunch of friends sneak into the facility
where mr takazawa's kept they try to
fiddle with the z001 and see what's
wrong with the old man haruko and the
gang are caught she tells the men that
mr takazawa sent her cries for help and
that's the only reason she's there the
men don't believe her and start
inspecting the machine haruko was right
the men thank her for being the source
of identifying the error in the machine
the men reassure the nurse that they'll
take good care of the old man just when
haruko and friends are about to leave
they hear the old man calling haruko's
name she tries unplugging the man from
the wires he's loaded with but is
smacked by one of the men he suggests
removing the wires might kill the man
the machine needs technical help
meanwhile haruko and her friends get
into a fight with the suited man the
machine starts moving the old man who
seems to be unconscious is operating the
machine and speaking through it he
requests haruko to take him home the
machine leaves busting through the door
in blazing speed the machine that
happens to be self-aware can transform
itself to adjust in the elevator all the
girls managed to escape but one of
haruko's male friend is left behind the
girls are riding the machine and is on
the road moving like a car they reach mr
tagazava's home to get his wife's
picture to cheer him up but the police
surround the house among these are
reporters too haruko decides to tell the
truth about mr takazawa to the reporters
before the police arrest them but alas
they're caught by the police just when
this is happening the machine acts up
but the man in the glasses turns it off
to settle everything down mr takazawa is
back in the facility and is being
monitored by a team of engineers it's
identified that there has been an error
in the primary data input the secretary
of health questions the team about the
black box that's supposed to identify
the problem in the machine there happens
to be a design flaw that's causing the
machine to act oddly haruko and her
friends are transferred to the seniors
wards and they get to keep their job in
the hospital they aren't even arrested
because if the world found out about the
ministry of public welfare failed with
the machine that would have been bad for
them haruko is still worried about the
old man her friends convinced her that
he might be fine since he hasn't sent a
new sos while doing her job haruko
learns that one of the patients in the
ward is a hacker and he's busting crimes
by reporting them anonymously haruko
asks him for a favor she wants him to
reach out to mr takazawa to help him out
the hacker manages to successfully
access z001 but the old man fails to
respond haruko investigates mr
takazawa's belongings and finds a
picture of his wife they do a simulation
of the wife's voice to get through to
the old man and he responds immediately
saying that he's in pain the ministry of
public welfare has used a biochip
computer to operate the machine and this
technology is fairly new
takashi hasegawa and others go to see mr
takazawa and the machine is a rectum
walking it manages to break through the
door and escape the facility he sees the
image of his wife and tends to follow it
destroying anything that comes in the
way haruko asks her friend to cover for
her while she heads out to meet mr
takazava who's still talking to his wife
and expresses the desire to go to the
beach it's all over the news that a man
operated by a robot is out on the
streets causing destruction takashi
comes looking for haruko in the hospital
hasigama suspects something on the
computer in the ward and steals floppy
disks from the computer the authorities
surround the site where mr takazawa is
at the same time they arrest haruko but
hear a voice the voice of a woman
demanding to let her go it's mr
takazawa's consciousness who's now
controlling the machine the machine goes
out of control and scares everyone
haruko talks to mrs takazawa basically
the machine and asks her if her husband
is fine the machine rushes across the
street hasigawa haruko and takashi are
now flying in a helicopter to find mr
takazawa it turns out hasigawa's
intentions weren't pure and this
experiment was merely a tool for him to
test the capabilities of the computer
and port akazawa became the victim
hasigava can tap into mr takazawa's
subconscious memory and he knows exactly
where the machine is headed there he is
the machine is flying in the air but
wait it's about to collide with the air
railway despite getting hit the machine
can lift itself at the top of the
railway track haruko tries to jump from
the helicopter to help the old man but
takashi holds her back the helicopter
loses balance while flying through the
trees and takashi falls off the
helicopter but the z001 captures him
it's too dangerous for the helicopter to
fly towards the machine so takashi is
alone with the machine mrs takazawa now
addresses takashi to come down as his
blood pressure is rising takashi
explains he intended to care for the
ailing elderly and he wants to win the
nobel prize but mrs takazawa stands in
the way mrs takazama tells him that the
machine is too clever and that he should
calm down as they head to the beach she
agrees to go back to the hospital once
they spend some time at the beach haruko
and hasegaw are at the beach too
hasegawa has ordered to park the
trailers and prepare to capture the
machine the moment it arrives takashi
and the machine have arrived too he
requests to remove the trailers but
instead of complying hasigar orders to
launch another machine the alpha it's
the military version of the z001 which
was developed parallel to the civilian
model unfortunately alpha is programmed
to follow hasagarva's orders only we're
about to witness hell or maybe something
else the z double 01 wraps wise around
the arms of the alpha machine but is
able to withstand the attack instead the
alpha reaches out and tries to break the
z001 but wait the patients at the
hospital have been able to hack and gain
control of z001 meanwhile the male nurse
friend is in the helicopter flying with
a bunch of tv reporters to rescue haruko
hasigava orders alpha to finish the job
before the reporters get to capture it
z001 can kick alpha get hastagava out of
the way and head through the tunnel to
get to the beach haruko and takashi
follow the machine onto the beach just
when they can reach the end of the
tunnel alpha in helicopter form attacks
the machine and tries to stop it after a
few fists and kicks z001 which is still
mrs takazawa separates mr takazawa from
the machine and tries to clear the way
and asks haruko to bring her husband to
the beach the male nurse comes into the
tunnel in an ambulance to rescue
everyone and they go to the beach
they're at the beach but alpha is
holding all doors haruko and the boy
managed to get out of the ambulance but
mr takazava is still in there the
patients from the hospital send a
message via the machine the only way to
stop alpha is to find the chip which is
at the top of the robot's bed takashi
hands over a cylinder to haruko to hit
the chip with and she starts climbing
but hasigawa is there too and he tries
to stop her after much struggling haruko
reaches the top and strikes the brain
with the cylinder but that wasn't enough
haruko asks mrs takazama to help and she
makes the final strike the alpha machine
finally gets destroyed the z double one
collapses but it's still functioning mr
takazawa mrs takazawa haruko and mr
takashi witnessed the sunset at the
beach mrs takazama bids farewell and
asks her husband to sleep before going
she says that they'll meet again soon
the cat we see at mr dakazawa's home
comes out of the machine and goes on a
stroll yoshihiko hasegawa the man in
charge of the robot is arrested all
thanks to the patients at the hospital
who have reported this mayhem
haruko and friends visit mr takazawa in
the hospital suddenly a destructive
noise appears it's mrs takazawa she and
the cat are back to see her husband
again and visit the beach everyone is
astounded to see her
so this is it for today's video if you
liked the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time